here is how to survive a zombie attack
in the movies if the movies are correct
the apocalypse can be a tough place to
live Mad Max had it easy
he just drive fast and you check out the
hot women but not all apocalypses are
equal in a zombie apocalypse things get
downright nasty your rent is cheap but
your neighbors are a nightmare so if you
want to survive a zombie apocalypse here
are a few things I learned according to
the movies don't worry about looking hot
or wearing a tank top to show up your
muscles get one of those dog training
outfits yeah dog training outfits I'm
where the everywhere is up by two you
might as well start practicing your most
disgusting brows because you're gonna be
one part of that band and you want to be
part of that man don't get bit it's as
simple as that like boxing pick yourself
of all times kid run most of these
idiots omni's are slow as dirt and have
a TD unless you get stuck going against
one of the CrossFit ones like 28 days
later if you're thinking about bashing
in some zombie heads don't go right for
the heavy baseball bats zombies heads
are like soft potatoes that have been in
the Sun too long
be honest you are never going to buy
that vintage record players to put those
old records to use practice your aim
dopey people shoot zombies in the leg
chest arms and balls George Romero
caught us shoot them in the brains be
creative and have fun while killing
zombies trackage oak to keep things
light plus
you saying there is no place for
emotional attachments in a zombie
apocalypse if somebody and your crew
gets sick you send the packet if they
let it samba use them in the snack
that's on them good bye see you later
nice knowing you and get yourself some
superpowers yep it's the movies so
nothing is off-limits look at Alice Oh
Alice she was smart and she got affected
and she didn't care she turned it into a
positive and the rest is history work
out I know the end of the world is a
pretty solid excuse to skip your workout
but God forbid you run into the rock
after he isn't pick up a dumbbell run up
a mountain or find an abandoned farm to
start a fitness center don't get
romantically involved with zombies
they're emotionally shallow some would
say cold and it never ends well and
frankly it's disgusting so that's it if
you're in a zombie predicament hopefully
these brilliant tips will help you
survive a few more hours now get that
dog suit don't be done
you